bien entendu c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se trouve pour s'affronter de nouveau
la dernière fois c'était sur un fps de
type quake aujourd'hui sur un fps de
type minecraft c'est juste un jeu avec
un peu les mêmes graphismes que
minecraft un petit peu cubique salle fps
qui jouent en ligne et ça a l'air d'être
un énorme pay to win vont la payer pour
gagner nous sommes en jeu je dois
choisir mon équipe
sniper team des bleus vous êtes prêt à
putte ainsi les touches américaine pour
avancer cw a on va faire le 3,69 scoop
cross map can't wait appel à temps mais
c'est 2-2 dans counter strike source à
bon sur les ennemis attendait mon la
ville doit se produire là-bas
aujourd'hui en dépit des chiottes mois
neuf fois encore c'est pas grave on en a
eu un de ses premiers contres comme on
dit un outil ça nulle part mais bon je
vois là bas au fond je vois là bas au
fond moi deux longues à strasbourg sera
formé dépêché à mon gars il va mourir
bataille nous met là mais arrêtez tous
bords qui voit là tiens c'était très
violent
je vois ta tête dépasse bah oui la
mienne aussi [ __ ] beurre le deuxième
là bas au fond je les fais attention
mais la demande dans le brouillard on
tire on fit grand bruit là vous pourrez
placer la barre pour dire non mais nous
défoncer doivent regarder le lui c'est
du hip hop à l'égard des marques ont
débarqué le gign dans game of thrones
voilà il y avait pas de gêne à l'époque
mais on s'en fout et acheter mal de
scoop 360
nos amis chinois baidu com a mis bon
conte vernis pas alors moi je me tuer
des gens en appel or je passe ensuite en
dvd connue est la leur tournée poubelle
mais bon allez on y va à l'appel merci
je l'aurais attentionné dans leur peau
dégâts bah oui attention je suis l'homme
qui saute et qui met des coups de pelle
hockey match en match je n'ai vu il m'a
vu j'ai vu plein alors outils sont mes
ou qui sont ils sont là et m'a mis un
tuyau il est où je suis sûr qu'il est là
où regarder
quel est le fuck il est là voilà il est
mort [ __ ] tient fait du hip hop tout
aussi fait du hip hop c'est parti les
gars en avance comme à nos auditeurs
fans de hockey ne servait à rien mais
j'étais quand même dans le rush du ggn
tu as tué mon pote je le vengerai
je les ai eus plus à envoyer médias sont
pas derrière un petit peu énervé si l'on
fait un jumeau pas hésité si un mois
j'ai découpé avec une balle là je pense
dans un grand délire nul sinon on est
arrivé au bout des choses comme ça on
est fâché il faut un blocus punk et oui
il faut un blocus était le lycée arrêté
le plan cul je veux aller à l'école
comprendre le style la drc easy avec le
snipe en tout de suite après les arbres
facile en tout de suite après un
traitement ok ok ok j'ai coupé leur
stratégie voilà bah c'est le business
est pas de mourir de préférence moi je
passe par là comme ça en marchant pas
qu'ils m'entendent refus connaît 32
c'est bien c'est qu'avant pas beaucoup
de bruit sur la map oh non non aux
moutures [ __ ] et c'est une routine de
mon moi ça suffit et là hop là et je
repars comme ça c'est comme si j'allais
à la boulangerie acheter du pain
j'arrive hop je prends la baguette et je
pars trop plein voilà alors vous vous je
détestais sportif je leur fais ça et ça
et ils font ça en retour ta gueule oui
j'ai bien aimé la paix légale appels oui
vous avez vu al fayed pète mais ça c'est
quoi à d'accord ok nickel asie et bien
on construit une sorte de chez pas être
beetle mature un pont un petit pour
voilà et là on passe en dessous comme ça
allait à je passe pas et c'est francis
je ne veux pas te tuer et de tuer nos
mondiaux chez vous ici qui se dressent
comme ça allez on remet des cubes
c'est n'importe quoi aux plats aux plats
aux noms j'aimais bien petit techniques
dus aux plats au plat voilà moi je
construis des murs suis pâtissier aussi
si tu veux un gland lits dont tu touches
pas à cannes 1 comme sa canne à cannes à
canach alain kahn à un disparu biarrote
de battlefront dit the war une seule
solution la cub ification voilà et là tu
te mets là et regardez rien les snipers
ou par deux fois encore vas-y vas-y un
premier jackson c'est bien jacques
sauter haut
j'attends aussi avec voyage à l'entrée
mais mais du coup j'ai juste des cubes
tube oh ne passerait pas mais attendez
vous ne passerez pas j'ai dit bon
arrêtez cassé mais qu un bon lui lui je
me le fais toi ta gueule à bientôt
arrêter pâte avec que plus tard au plat
ou plat je t'ai vu la capelle à léo
castelli pomper des trompe edel on
pénètre qu'autant dafa
pardon non on a perdu on n'a pas perdu
rien n'est perdu il suffit d'augmenter
et de tuer on a perdu on va maintenant
jouer en mode carnage et j'ai aucune
[ __ ] idée de ce que c'est as un truc
qui doit jouer qu'elle appelle c'est ça
attendez je sais que je sais comment
faire chier les gens il faut engager à
un contre un et ensuite le soufflé
regarder et dont tu m'auras pas énoncer
raté désolé et non à bientôt
ben pourquoi mais pourquoi tu es énervé
né soit pas fâché salut je crois qu'il a
flashé sur moi lui regardez comme ils me
regardent
or navigue à la hausse dépassait pas été
touchée mais ils bougent comme ça où je
sais quoi faire je sais quoi faire et
non tu m'auras pas au qatar les enfants
ils ont détruit la tour j'ai maintenant
le n96 à à regarder que je viens
d'acheter 2 euros 60 watts à la moitié
du prix d'un greg bordel pour un secteur
occupé vraiment pour faire des
magnifiques 360 au sco plus grosses
papilles the grinder goren assez honteux
quam et royal tout est payant que tu
passes des niveaux tu débloques pas des
armes tu débloques le moyen d'acheter
des armes avec des vrais ou faux quoi
c'est horrible nous sommes de retour sur
de dust2 avec mon équipe de tueurs si
vous jouez à un jeu franchement bref
stévia m'ont acheté des armes c'est
quand même du foutage de gueule attendez
on est prêts là on va mettre des noces
comme 3 soit sport beach alors c'est bon
ça one shot pas ya juste une lunette en
fait donc c'est ça ça voilà coûte 2
euros 60 très bien [ __ ] al gore gauche
couvre vos arrières je propose la fin
j'ai ce soit avec vannes où tu as une
balle tous les trois ps comment vos
arrières quand même ne vous inquiétez
pas hopla mois voilà mes fins bon suivi
et meurt devant moi lol ça te fait rire
ça fait rire la dame
le mec qui se frustre et garder le job
non les gens au tennis quoi je fais s'il
fonce à 360 me laisse moi finir mon tour
60 se plaît et souha gens aimables un
peu on attendait bien c'est bien un truc
à faire là dedans attention attention
bon jeu derrière toi tu voles regarder
au plan d eau un bunker mec mais là on
est trop bien regardez moi ça ils se
doutent de rien et en place à tête
dépasser j'ai raté mais c'est un endroit
rêvé pour un gros concours perco hop là
où tu as eu honte à tête dépasser les
marques perret isabelle bleau m'a repéré
les gars on tue quelqu'un en son nom
mais les mecs qui sont là-haut l'a
observé nos calvitie comment sort du
sport attention aux noms des marqueurs
c'est un cac ce compaq x comme un coucou
aux nues la fédé l'année tout sur ce jeu
je les veux y avait trois personnes il a
gagné un kinder je suis avec maxime
j'ai avec mes preuves avec mon games
quand tu n'es pas
dans le game à l'acte pour sniper tubize
et tu mets à est de choc
tu as peur peur peur
non non on avait à quatre on est là bas
4 1 je suis tellement déçu mais je vais
faire une phrase on mise sur ce jeu avec
des effets styles et tous genres quiz
est retenu mais encore une fois comme ça
et je te jure que je dis cela avec des
vidéos on may think it est au ralenti le
fourbe nous sommes sur une nouvelle map
il passait par là qui s'appelle et
c'était pas le moment là où il ya
peut-être regardez regardez à l'appel à
la paix longue salon et a fait semblant
il a fait son boulot je veux mettre mon
372 qu avant d'arrêter s'il vous plaît
laissez moi le maître comme ça ni vu ni
connu
non c'est parti moi je voulais dire
bonjour pas vraiment eu c'était un peu
plus agressif il est beau et un mec là
bas protégez moi hein tu peux plus me
protéger alors je gt2 par contre si tu
es tout cela nous sommes les cubains tu
mets pas des coups quand je te plaît oh
oui mais voilà gens c'est déjà moins de
sept vidéo sur ben le criera sur ce jeu
j'ai trouvé assez cool mais je suis déçu
que ce soit un free-to-play puisqu'au
final battu doit payer pour voir des
meilleurs arrêts pour ba gagner plus
facilement pourquoi pas l'avoir fait
juste arrêt de 10 ou 15 euros et ensuite
tu es tranquille tu achètes faut jamais
rien c'est pas parce que j'ai acheté un
truc comme ça pour déconner pour vous
montrer qu'il faut que vous fassiez
pareil en tout cas c'était cool d'avoir
joué contre vous comme d'hab vous avez
votre petit niveau et ça me rend
vraiment regarder mes bras se resserre
c'est la frustration j'espère que ça
vous a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle passer de
bonnes vacances de noël et je vais dire
à chaque vidéo jusqu'à noël bat witcher
tout le monde
pitts